[Musique]
regardant un livre justement sur les
femmes la politique qui est assez récent
et donc on parlera peut-être de la
situation des femmes parce qu'elles sont
au premier plan ne serait-ce qu'avec la
première ministre Elisabeth borne
bonjour vous êtes la mère de Chevreuse
alors le maire de mer pardon il préfère
de ma fille
c'est votre compte Twitter exactement
bravo pour les deux
bonjour bonjour vous êtes toujours
éditeur toujours éditeur et des éditions
la journée
[Musique]
[Rires]
à l'université de Paris-Saclay voilà et
on va parler justement avec vous de
cette réforme des retraites et de donner
économique évidemment qui qui est
importante mais on va peut-être
commencer par le premier sujet est-ce
que finalement dans ce débat tout le
monde n'est pas piégé
[Musique]
voilà c'est quelle leçon on peut tirer
justement après les manifestations qui
ont qui sont nombreuses qui sont nourris
on a vu samedi
dans toute la France il y a notamment
dans les petites villes il y a une très
grande mobilisation Armelle comment vous
vous jugez cette
ce face-à-face au fond entre une partie
importante de la France et le pouvoir je
pense que c'est
véritable succès pour les syndicats ils
étaient en perte de vitesse à tout point
de vue il y a jamais eu énormément
d'adhésion si on compare au syndicats
d'autres pays mais les adhésions étaient
complètement tombée et là il y a eu un
recrudescence depuis déjà la première
manifestation une recrudescence des
adhésions et d'autre part les syndicats
organisés des manifestations il y en a
plusieurs maintenant derrière nous et on
a encore de nos corps et ces
manifestations ont été on peut dire
remarquable dans l'ordre dans lequel
elles se sont déroulées rien à voir avec
les gilets jaunes ou les bonnets rouges
il y a eu un changement de préfet de
police aussi ça peut peut-être
ça peut peut-être jouer donc oui mais il
y a la police et puis il y a les
syndicats et il y a les syndicats il y a
eu une bonne entente entre les deux dans
l'organisation même dans l'organisation
même des manifestations ce qui est
effectivement n'avait pas été le cas
avec le
précédent donc je pense que
beaucoup attendent que les l'unité
syndicale se disloquent on en est pas là
on en a encore loin de là et je pense
que pour le moment les seuls gagnants si
on peut parler de gagnant dans une
situation qui est effectivement piégée
et bien ce sont pour le moment les
syndicats
de police c'est surtout sur Paris mais
je pense que ce qui est notable c'est
que on retrouve en France des
manifestations qui se passent bien qui
se passe bien
alors il y a eu le problème du enfin le
problème la question du préfet de police
de Paris effectivement mais c'est quand
même des années qu'on voyait des
manifestations se terminer
avec des images dramat qui qui faisait
que ce mouvement syndical petit à petit
il y avait une image de plus en plus
négative alors syndical ou pas
puisqu'effectivement il y a eu les
gilets jaunes mais il y a certaines
manifestations aussi syndicales qui se
finissait par le premier mec qui se
finissait très très mal voilà je pense
que ça c'est le premier enseignement qui
faut en tirer l'unité syndicale
effectivement semble fragile depuis le
début mais tiens ce qui ce qui vraiment
est aussi assez on n'a pas vu depuis
suffisamment longtemps on sent que du
côté de la CGT notamment et de il y a
une volonté de peut-être de renforcer le
mouvement de le rendre
plus vindicatif
ce à quoi leur aubergé peut-être de la
CFDT neadera pas on verra dans les jours
qui viennent la difficulté c'est que si
on tombe dans un mouvement plus enfin à
mon avis si on tombe dans un mouvement
plus dur ou avec une image plus négative
donc des manifestation qui se finissent
mal le mouvement aura beaucoup moins de
soutien du pays aujourd'hui c'est un
mouvement qui qui remporte l'adhésion du
pays
quel que soit son avis sur la réforme
des retraites c'est un mouvement qui est
vu positivement si on retombe dans des
images de manifestation qui se finissent
de manière catastrophique ou de blocage
ou de transport comme on avait eu
rappelez-vous le mois de décembre avant
le avant le covid avant on avait tout un
mois de décembre qui avait été bloqué
déjà par la réforme des retraites V1
enfin Macron version 1 ça avait été une
horreur et quand tout le monde se
retrouve pris au piège assez rapidement
l'image du mouvement social devient
devient négative dans l'opinion publique
et je pense que pour l'instant ils
arrivent à rester sur un espèce de fil
du rasoir qui fait que on n'a pas encore
cette image pas encore
par exemple des contrôleurs du ciel
samedi voilà donc les gens étaient les
aéroports
comme ça qui se passent peut-être que la
popularité en effet du mouvement risque
de se retourner ou les raffineries
peuvent paralyser complètement la France
donc les raffineries comme on l'a vu il
y a quelques mois pour d'autres raisons
ce qu'il faudrait savoir surtout c'est
ce que c'est qu'une grève illégale parce
que
qu'est-ce qui va advenir des contrôleurs
aériens parce que si on fait une grève
illégale et qui ne se passe rien qui ne
sont pas concernés
vu notre statut hyper privilégié on
préfère pas s'en mêler mais là il y a
une grève illégale mais qu'est-ce qui va
se passer sans doute rien et donc c'est
un blanc simple donné à n'importe qui de
faire les grèves illégales n'importe
quand alors on sait bien qu'à la SNCF
par exemple il dépose peu près 300
préavis de grève déposer tous les matins
sur le bureau du patron de la SNCF pour
justement être dans la légalité enfin au
moins on sauve les apparences donc ça
c'est extrêmement troublant donc est-ce
que quelqu'un pourra nous donner une
réponse est-ce que c'est c'est cette
grève illégale
j'aimerais que depuis l'autre chose qui
m'épate mais il y a deux choses
l'absence des blagues blocs alors est-ce
que c'est des c'est à vous écouter on a
l'impression que c'est grâce au syndicat
qui a pas de Black Bloc alors est-ce que
avant il y avait des Black Blocs à cause
des syndicats je sais pas c'est eux qui
dirigent les Black Blocs
on pourrait dire
donc pour moi
ces Black Blocs ont disparu ils ont été
dissous je sais pas c'est merveilleux
alors si quelqu'un la recette pour
manipuler les Black Blocs il y a une
manipulation parce que visiblement et
puis enfin la dernière chose qui m'épate
c'est que on ne donne quasiment plus la
parole aux gens qui peuvent soutenir
cette réforme c'est-à-dire que partout
dans tous les médias on entend que des
gens pour dire oui c'est scandaleux on
entend de 18 ans qu'on n'aime pas
commencer à bosser qui sont déjà épuisés
à l'idée même de tenir une clé à molette
ou de ou d'ouvrir un ordinateur il y a
non pourra jamais tenir jusqu'à 64 ans
je veux dire on est dans une aberration
et plus personne ne défend il y a plus
aucun sur aucun média on dit bah oui
c'est très fort mais il est intéressant
oui il faut la faire oui c'est bien
alors je veux bien qu'en plus le
gouvernement sur une balle dans le pied
que ce truc ridicule des 1200 euros
quelle personne ne comprend rien ils
sont tous en train de nager ça c'est les
communication du gouvernement c'est
incapable d'expliquer eux-mêmes
erreurs de débutants mais voilà c'est
c'est trois points là qui me qui me
choquent est-ce que finalement tout se
piéger c'est vrai que on est dans un
dans un état où le gouvernement ne peut
pas céder et les syndicats ne peuvent
pas s'aider on est dans notre ferme
bras de fer un bras de fer personne ne
peut reculer quoi pour l'instant les
menaces sont plus efficaces que de
passer à l'acte donc
ça fait régulièrement dans l'action
syndicale les menaces sont toujours
est-il plus efficaces que le
déclenchement de conflits de grève parce
qu'on voit bien qu'à mesure que le
conflit perdure il s'émoussent et le
pouvoir de nuisances devient
contre-productif pour celui qui l'a
initié donc ici on a un bras de fer
entre syndicat et gouvernement et je
dirais qu'à la limite la question est
plus de savoir qui va lâcher en premier
qui va lâcher un peu plus et ce un peu
plus qui va faire pencher la balance
donc ça c'est une possibilité mais ce
qu'on sent bien aussi c'est que une
ambivalence dans tout dans toutes les
catégories et dans toutes les catégories
de population et dans tous les thèmes
qu'on peut développer au sens où on a
une partie de la population qui est
contre le recul de l'âge mais qui sent
la nécessité de la réforme donc on a
quand même cette ce double problème on a
une partie des électeurs d'Emmanuel
Macron qui ont voté Macron second tour
mais qui n'étaient pas pour Emmanuel
Macron premier tour qui ont fait plus
barrage à Marine Le Pen que voter pour
Emmanuel Macron et qui aujourd'hui se
sente finalement assez libre avec son
programme en disant j'ai voté pour le
personnage mais pas pour le programme or
il me semble quand même qu'en démocratie
voilà et quand démocratie oui voter
contre Le Pen quand démocratie ne peut
pas voter contre quelqu'un qui ne vous
convient pas et ne pas prendre le
programme de celui pour qui vous votez
quand on vote c'est le candidat et son
programme donc ça c'est assez
normalement c'est assez rationnel le
problème ici c'est que et certains le
soulignent aussi c'est qu'il y a
peut-être une incompréhension dans cette
adhésion au programme d'Emmanuel Macron
certains disent mais finalement c'est
pas dans ma c'est pas dans ma
philosophie donc je ne me sens pas
obligé par ce programme et c'est une
façon de dire finalement la démocratie
c'est le peuple souverain qui dépose sa
souveraineté à l'occasion des élections
et une fois que les élections sont
passées celui qui est au pouvoir doit
appliquer le programme pour lequel il a
été élu donc normalement les lecteurs ne
peut pas dire ça ne me convient pas
puisque c'est les urnes qui lui donnent
l'occasion de s'exprimer et entre deux
élections le peuple souverain regarde ce
qui se passe c'est un peu c'est un peu
la situation il est dépensibilité voilà
c'est une légitimité qui est difficile à
contester de façon très très toute chose
étant égale pareil parce qu'après bien
sûr quand on parle de légitimité vous
évoquez le le nombre de gens qui ont
voté pour ou contre Emmanuel Macron
enfin il a été donc élu démocratiquement
et c'est très bien mais voilà par une je
pose la question par qui a été élu
monsieur Martinez combien de dizaines de
personnes l'ont appelées en quoi est-ce
qu'il serait plus représentatifs
syndicale en France le problème c'est
qu'on la mesure pas comme dans les
autres pays la créditation préalable
n'existe pas donc le les troupes des
syndicats ça ne veut rien dire et
d'ailleurs certains disent oui mais ça
ne veut strictement rien dire et ce
qu'on peut remarquer aussi c'est que les
syndicats ici je considère quand même
qu'ils arrivent à entraîner derrière eux
derrière des banderoles finalement qui
restent des banderoles syndicales et
syndicats sont devant les politiques
sont derrière c'est bien ce que demander
syndicats mais on a aussi dans les
manifestations de samedi des
manifestations qui ne sont pas très
syndicales le sens où il y avait des
familles entières dont je suppose que
là il y a voilà il y a pas que le
syndicat
je vais bloquer là je vais bloquer la
France je vais mettre la France à
l'arrêt il est là on lui donne la parole
comme si c'était une une figure
incroyable non c'est pas une figure
prête
combien de gens combien
derrière euh
effectivement on pense tout de suite
démocratie représentative c'est-à-dire
on élit on élit quelqu'un qui est une
assemblée pour 5 ans et puis pour
l'instant là bah il se passe rien mais
la démocratie c'est aussi le droit de
grève le droit de manifester et puis on
y viendra peut-être le référendum donc
c'est ça qui peut qui peut vivre la
démocratie entre deux élections mais à
ce sujet là moi je trouve qu'on est
particulièrement maladroit en France
avec l'utilisation de ce système
démocratique puisque vous le disiez
normalement votre paradisions et non pas
contre sauf que toute l'histoire de la
Cinquième République elle est basée sur
des votes contre le premier tour on
choisit au deuxième on élimine c'est la
règle de la sécurité publique même si on
prend l'exemple des référendums enfin
des références
la personne qui a posé la question
exactement et c'est l'histoire de toute
la Cinquième République alors on nous a
pas enchanté avec des référendum sur
lesquels
la société a pu sentir impliquée on a eu
un certain nombre de choses sur l'Europe
qui était des dossiers quand même
particulièrement technique et à part il
y a une question absolument énorme
la première fois que j'ai voté c'était
pour un référendum et la question posée
vous en souviendrez peut-être c'était
êtes-vous favorable à
l'autodétermination de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie oui j'avais 18 ans
et j'avais une vague idée douce située
la Nouvelle-Calédonie encore plus vague
idée de son histoire et absolument
aucune idée de ce que voulait dire
l'autodétermination et on me demande mon
avis forcément enfin vous voyez on a mal
utilisé ces outils là et je pense qu'on
est dans une société plus contre que
pour mais j'avais une question à poser à
la profère de sciences politiques
ce que disait Véronique Jérôme
conteste la légitimité de d'Emmanuel
Macron et une contestation de la
légitimité de sa légitimité à faire des
réformes même celles
il a annoncé pendant sa campagne mais
c'est vrai que si dans le système de la
Cinquième République quand vous faites
des réformes quand vous faites vous
appliquez votre programme vous êtes
réduit quand même au score que vous avez
eu au premier tour et si on regarde les
choses lui il a fait 27 %
supposons Pécresse c'était était pour
pour la réforme aussi des retraites à
eux deux ça fait 32% et on retrouve bien
les 68% de Français qui sont contre la
réforme c'est à dire qu'on est il est
vraiment remis vous voyez son score du
premier tour quoi c'est ça pose alors
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas réformer des
institutions pour essayer d'avoir je
sais pas peut-être un soutien plus vaste
dès le premier tour je sais pas comment
faire mais est-ce que c'est vrai que ça
ne pose pas un problème cette au fond ce
premier est un deuxième tour quoi aux
élections et oui mais vous venez de le
dire comment faire comment faire et je
pense que la réforme devrait être
beaucoup plus globale sur les pouvoirs
même du président de la République
puisqu'on est quand même dans une très
très
donc voilà c'est ça c'est pas c'est pas
simplement une question de premier
deuxième tour ou comment élire le
prétend de la République on va pas
revenir au fait qu'il y ait une élection
avec des grands électeurs comme c'était
le cas avant la réforme
autour de nous je pense que la France
n'est pas aujourd'hui les mentalités
françaises sont pas adaptées à un
système comme l'Allemagne c'est ce qui
pourrait enfin avec les coalitions etc
c'est ce qui devrait se passer
quand on regarde autour de nous sur les
systèmes démocratiques proches d'une
autre j'ai pas l'impression qu'il y a
des systèmes qui puissent nous faire
particulièrement en vie moi j'aime le
système italien on le sait depuis 20 ans
la politique italienne tient de manière
assez bancale c'est d'ailleurs leur
niveau économique et pas professionnel
j'ai pas forcément séduisant non plus le
système anglais est encore assez
différent avec avec
une notion de l'intérêt commun un petit
peu un petit peu différente de la nôtre
effectivement c'est un traite
churchillien mais c'est un système avec
plein de travers mais mais les
améliorations sont pas faciles à
apporter
deux têtes de l'exécutif et on l'a vu
parfois dans les réunions
internationales ou le président voulait
les tout seul le premier ministre
dans les cas de cohabitation
si on avait boutit toutes ces exemples
et on avait simplement un premier ou une
première ministre qui soit chef de
gouvernement et qu'on soit pas chapeauté
par un président qui en définitive fait
de son premier ministre un collaborateur
comme disait Sarkozy
Fillon peut-être que déjà ce serait plus
équilibré parce que bon on voit pas très
bien très souvent comment et quelle est
la marge de manœuvre du Premier ministre
et actuellement de
d'Elizabeth borne sauf à rester droit
dans ses bottes de ne pas avoir des
dates
sa légitimité du
finalement pas si elle est élu elle est
dégoûtée
absolue à l'Assemblée
on peut dérouler effectivement là c'est
plus compliqué au premier ministre c'est
le bouclier donc de faire par avance
donc là pour le Président c'est quand
même finalement une situation
confortable donc on peut même en savoir
plus
dans le débat de retraite la première
ministre que c'est très explicite si
c'était pas le cas précédemment c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que cette fonction
de bouclier alors c'est pour vous dire
au débat institutionnel elle marchait
mieux du temps du septena quand les
quand les temps de pouvoir n'était pas
les mêmes entre eux entre entre le
président et le législatif
on se souvient de Chirac il pouvait très
bien dire
chemise avec Macron enfin jusqu'à leur
divorce-philippe c'est que aujourd'hui
il peut déclarer ce qu'il veut personne
n'écoute tout le monde ne parle de
savoir pourquoi il a plus de de sourcils
c'est vrai
de la télévision
un article on interroge justement un
concert de sciences politiques il faut
dire est-ce qu'on peut être élu quand on
est laid
donc c'est vrai que le pouvoir il a fait
une grande interview
en fait
mais c'est vrai que c'est alors un mot
quand même sur le sur le Parlement
puisque là il a il devrait avoir un rôle
essentiel ce qui se passe actuellement
quand même ça grandit pas
ni son rôle ni les députés non un rôle
essentiel j'ai l'impression qu'on
allaitration même que on est comme vous
le disiez dans un système très
présidentiel puisque le rôle du
Parlement finalement est annulé par ces
discussions là on sait que si les
amendements ne sont pas retirés toutes
les discussions qui ont eu lieu au
Parlement se passera pas grand chose on
l'a vu précédemment on n'ira pas
jusqu'au bout du texte on l'a vu
précédemment avec le 49-3 on discute on
discute mais à la fin si on tranche
toutes les discussions du Parlement sont
annulées le rôle d'enrichissement du
Parlement qui à mon avis est le seul qui
puisse encore exister
ne peut pas ne peut pas être efficience
sur une sur une réforme comme celle-là
alors sur des trucs très techno
effectivement on va pas avoir
l'emballement médiatique on va pas avoir
plutôt de l'image qui est donnée dans
les débats avec mon histoire
du socle
et qui nous coûte après localement enfin
moi je suis élu locale on se rend compte
de l'évolution je me plains pas du tout
et beaucoup d'élus qui se plaignent faut
pas rigoler personne ne les a obligé
d'aller là où ils sont donc il faut
rester tout à fait serein mais qui
contribue à à rendre l'élu un peu
punching ball c'est à dire que on voit
l'Assemblée nationale des gens
s'insultaient se taper dessus je vais
faire de faire du du buzz j'aime pas
cette expression mais je trouve pas
d'équivalent sur le ballon du socle ou
sur enfin voilà
c'est violent quoi ça vient un petit peu
de de Nicolas Sarkozy avait un petit peu
entamé l'image ici à sa manière mais
surtout de François Hollande ce
président normal et puis petit à petit
de président normal on est devenu le
copain et puis du copain on est devenu
le enfin et aujourd'hui ça abîme
l'ensemble de l'organisation politique
c'est à dire que la cour de récréation à
laquelle on assiste à l'Assemblée où on
dirait des des gamins prépubères ça se
reporte après sur nous pardon je suis
peut-être un peu violente dans nos
propres moi des gens qui viennent qui
rentrent dans mon bureau pour
m'engueuler traiter tous les noms parce
qu'ils ont pris une contravention de
stationnement c'était quelque chose
qu'on voyait pas il y a quelques années
et aujourd'hui c'est sans filtre c'est
sans filtre il y a aussi le pour moi la
fin des politiques à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est à dire que là maintenant
il y a n'importe qui qui arrive à
l'Assemblée
on a un type qui était animateur chez
Hanouna qui devient député de la France
insoumise enfin je veux dire c'est c'est
quand même le grand n'importe quoi alors
faut pas faut pas s'attendre à ce que
ces gens soudainement parce qu'ils ont
une écharpe tricolore et qu'ils ont été
élus deviennent responsables intelligent
et posé donc ils font pas ils font pas
de la politique font de l'agitation ils
se font ils se font entendre ils ont
leur petit quart d'heure de célébrité
c'est à celui qui est notamment la
nupaise dira la plus la plus grosse
énorme idée de façon à ce qu'il soit
repris ça tourne en boucle sur toutes
les chaînes télévision voilà donc c'est
un peu la fin de la politique à
l'Assemblée pour l'instant donc on ne
voit plus un seul homme politique une
femme politique c'est-à-dire qui
s'exprime c'est fini
le dernier
des membres de l'Assemblée non mais
sinon bien évidemment
mais il y avait des trucs très violents
le lendemain de la mort de je ne sais
plus quel président de la République qui
avait écrit dans le journal le président
machin est mort hier ce matin j'ai
compté tous les Français il en manque
pas
dans les années 30 il y a eu des
violences oui beaucoup beaucoup très
très fortes
quand même une image de l'assemblée qui
est pas très reluisante tu vois non ce
qui est grave c'est pour les locaux
parce que le maire est quand même la
personnalité préférée des français dans
les hommes politiques le maire avec
cette proximité et aujourd'hui si je
vous entends finalement vous êtes
vraiment mais il y avait un sondage vous
disais apporter
contre les élus qui ça c'est nouveau
cette réserve cette comme avec pardon
comme avec l'instituteur le médecin
et et comme on est dans une société qui
est relativement éruptive et sans pour
autant quand on regarde de près sans
pour autant que ça aille plus mal que ça
n'allait il y a 20 ans il y a 30 ans il
y a 40 ans mais comme la voix de tout le
monde porte à un niveau à peu près
équivalent alors c'est facile de dire
voilà c'est mais c'est
le dada de tout le monde mais il est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui avec les réseaux
sociaux la voix de tout le monde peut
porter de manière équivalente
les opinions politiques d'un joueur de
foot vont être aussi important que les
miennes en matière de sélection de
l'équipe de France de enfin voilà tout
se vaut et donc comme tout ce veau tout
se voit aussi humainement et donc cette
espèce de respect de de distance de de
je demande pas qu'on se mettait genou
devant moi c'est pas du tout ça mais je
je voudrais faire la différence entre la
personne que je suis et la fonction que
j'ai et dans cette fonction là il y a
plus de filtre il y a plus de filtre
dans une société ruptive qui pourtant on
regarde tous les indicateurs sociétaux
de prêt n'a pas plus de raison d'être
énervé aujourd'hui qu'il y a 20 ans ou
30 ans
mais il a un poutching-ball sur lequel
mais franchement quand on voit ces
images on voit ça
moi aussi je vais aller tu vas voir ce
que je vais lui mettre mais c'est sûr
aussi que d'arriver en tongs à fleurs à
l'Assemblée ça donne pas non plus une
image très respectable des élus voilà ça
c'est une évidence c'est bon comme tout
le monde a lâché les dix ou dans ben
c'est pas grave venez en maillot de bain
c'est pas
l'habit ne fait pas le moine si je pense
que la biche et le moine bien évidemment
l'accusait de venir à convention avec
bon à l'époque c'était les états
dentelle et tout et il a répondu mais au
contraire j'y tiens parce que c'est par
respect pour le peuple bien évidemment
et je sais plus qui disait justement
quelle idée ils se font du peuple
parce que le peuple n'est pas forcément
pour les les
gens qui viennent tout à fait de peu
noyer et je crois qu'il y a aussi un
respect parfois que demande le peuple
contrairement à ce que croire certains
et c'est dans tous les domaines parce
que Philippe Bizet l'ancienne avocat
général me disait quand il a commencé sa
carrière quand les membres enfin qui
allaient devenir juré arriver ils
étaient tous quelle que soit la classe
sociale en costume cravate alors
certains on voyait que c'était la
première fois qu'ils mettaient un
costume etc mais il dit à la fin de sa
carrière il y a très peu d'années il m'a
dit je vois des gens arriver en chemise
à fleurs et en tongs et les types ils
viennent pour juger des gens et ils vont
peut-être leur mettre 30 ans de prison
et sont là il y a plus aucun ils sont là
les mains dans les poches presque en
situation il y a plus aucune aucun
respect aucune sacralisation
aussi importante que la justice ou
effectivement la présentation nationale
le médecin
l'enseignant le
effectivement tout ce qui représente
siècle notable un mot avant de parler
est-ce qu'il y a pas une contradiction
dans le mouvement syndical du soutien
populaire est-ce que chez des gens qui
manifestent alors est-ce qu'il y a pas
une contradiction entre le fait de se
dire bah j'ai pas envie de travailler 2
ans de plus et puis le fait de se dire
oui mais s'il y a pas de réformes
j'aurais peut-être pas de retraite
finalement tous les problèmes
alors si on suit de façon assez basique
les choses et si on suit la façon dont
les choses ont été présentées sont suit
la pédagogie qui a été annoncée parce
que Gabriel Attal encore lancé pas de
réforme c'est la faillite donc là on a
cette vision là on a comment le rapport
du corps qui finalement est la Bible ce
à quoi tout le monde se réfère mais le
souci enfin on en avait parlé il y a
déjà je crois pratiquement à moi c'est
que ces données qui sont faits par le
corps avec des projections à échéance
2030 ça peut aller 2050 2070 aucun
économiste voilà sérieux n'est capable
de vous dire à 2070 avec une certitude
assez précise de quoi de quoi de quoi
sera fait le pays comment sera
l'environnement donc premièrement il y a
une difficulté à donner à des
projections qui sont forcément en
caractères probabiliste c'est-à-dire le
risque zéro n'existe pas le risque de se
tromper donc forcément la prévision elle
peut parfaite donc on sait qu'il y aura
une marge d'erreur la question de savoir
quelle est la taille de la marge
d'erreur parce que plus la marge est
large plus ça peut remettre en cause on
le voit bien quand il y a des sondages
si la marche d'erreur est très très
large finalement on est sur le fil le
candidat peut gagner ou perdre et ça ne
sert plus rien de faire un sondage là la
question c'est que ça repousse sur des
hypothèses notamment de croissance et de
comment de taux de chômage qui sont liés
d'ailleurs de toute façon qui ont été
envisagés de façon un peu arbitraire en
considérant que le taux de chômage
allait baisser à 4 et demi puis repartir
ensuite à 7% qui est sa vitesse de
croisière ce qu'on arrive peut-être le
plus à quand on a bien maîtrisé on
arrive à 7 4 et demi c'est hautement
optimiste c'est très optimiste et ça et
on ne je vais eu cette expression mais
on ne décrète pas un taux de chômage
quand François Hollande a commencé la
première année de ses vœux au soir
je vais mais je m'engage je vais
inverser la courbe du chômage et tous
les ans il resservait cette même
promesse il ne faut pas s'étonner que la
religion de pouvoir
il a voulu il a voulu climatiser
l'opinion donc il a entraîné il a
entretenu cet espoir l'entretient pas à
l'espoir de ce que tu ne peux de ce que
l'on ne peut espérer voilà c'est mais ça
ne marche pas on ne manipule pas dans le
sens je dirais que du terme on ne peut
pas manipuler les attentes des électeurs
parce que de toute façon ce qui se passe
c'est passé avec François Hollande il a
même pas eu le courage d'aller se
présenter aux élections il savait très
bien qu'il aurait été remercié par de
tels s'engagement il y avait des étapes
économiques qui fait qu'après des
croissants sur la croissance etc pas
forcément marché comme il le souhaitait
et puis ça n'est pas suffisant pour
inciter c'est ça qui est très frappant
dans ce débat et qu'il leur rend
compliqué c'est que si vous écoutez et
les économistes vous avez autant
d'économistes qui vous disent qu'il faut
absolument cette réforme que que des
conneries ce qui vous disent absolument
pas elle sert à rien et on peut s'en
passer aussi sur la façon de financer
il y a une interview de assez
intéressante dans la main
deuxième point
qui dit au fond cette réforme c'est pas
du tout pour remettre l'équilibre dans
la dans la dans les retraites c'est pour
donner un gage au marché financier ce
qui après tout pas totalement idiot
c'est-à-dire que on a on a un taux
d'emprunt qui est de 0,5 % plus fort que
que l'Allemagne et c'est d'essayer
justement de pas avoir un taux qui
s'envole par rapport à l'Allemagne et
après tout c'est pas totalement et idiot
non plus de d'avoir une sorte de
crédibilité internationale pour la
France le mot marché financier il va
remettre 100000 personnes de plus c'est
quand même mais après tout presque
maintenant l'huile sur le feu mais après
tout regardez les marchés financiers
quand la la première ministre
anglaise a commencé à vouloir faire des
choses
très libérales qui n'ont pas plus non
plus au marché financier elle a été viré
dans les dans les deux je sais pas
combien de temps elle est restée trousse
jamais manqué un petit peu de mesures
aussi
le diable absolu mais parfois c'est
aussi on ne peut pas faire n'importe
quoi sauf si on est suffisamment
important parce que finalement les
États-Unis sont toujours comportés en
considérant tous les tout fait enfin
c'est trop gros pour pour chuter pardon
Jean-Charles et en considérant c'est
notre déficit mais c'est votre problème
à l'Europe donc c'est un peu dans cet
esprit là que l'après breton Woods et
cette époque de la presse seconde guerre
où les États-Unis finalement ont eu le
dessus parce que le dollar était monnaie
véhicule international
internationalement utilisé dans tous les
échanges et que la puissance de la
monnaie peut donner finalement des
occasions de d'être un peu plus je
dirais distant avec le déficit et là le
problème c'est que là où un hamac n'a
pas complètement tort c'est c'est la
signature de la France on a vu que les
agents ont commencé à nous dégrader un
petit peu
en 83 avec Mitterrand mais on pourra pas
trop loin non plus parce qu'on est quand
même on est inséré dans l'Union europ
donc je ne peux pas faire tomber un
maillon sans imaginer entraîner les
autres donc on est un peu là encore sur
une demi-mesure c'est pas complètement
faux mais c'est pas complètement vrai
non plus on ne peut pas tout donner au
marché financier
semble assez clair c'est que quand on a
3000 milliards de déficit on est déjà
soumis donc on a pas une liberté absolue
non plus
sans remonter au XIXe siècle en étant
mais mais la société et on le voit
également dans les jeunes qui rentrent
dans le marché du travail ils ont une
approche au travail qui est très grave
au travail qui est très différent je
veux télétrailler je veux pas d'horaire
fixe je veux pas m'engager un CDD ça me
va très bien donc c'est je pense qu'on
est sur un vrai débat philosophique sur
la valeur du travail qui aujourd'hui a
une image très négative or et comme vous
le disiez on ne donne plus la parole à
ces gens qui se qui
avait des offres d'emploi par exemple de
la communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin et la première chose qu'on
dit télétravail possible et c'est quand
même incroyable
ne vous inquiétez pas télétravail
possible et 4 l'idée c'est bientôt 4
jours par semaine pourquoi pas
c'est un vrai débat oui mais ça
participe exactement si on dit aux gens
vous inquiétez pas le boulot vous allez
y aller le moins possible et puis toute
façon dans ce moins possible ça sera
quatre jours sur 7 pourquoi pas bientôt
3 mais cela dit
je me demande si la réforme des
retraites ne serait pas passé plus
facilement s'il y avait aussi une
contrepartie peut-être sur la réduction
du temps de travail l'allongement dans
le temps mais peut-être la réduction
dans la semaine pourquoi pas non mais
c'est des problèmes qui peuvent
s'évoquer c'est pas forcément France
d'assister dès son plus jeune âge
différemment le peut-être plus longtemps
dans la vie
comme ça la clé du problème c'est qu'à
la fin le travail aujourd'hui on est
dans des mesures d'évitement comment va
faire pour raccourcir
vous parlez de valeur de travail et on
parle de valeur travail c'est ce terme
de valeur qui peut véritablement
interroger quand on écoute
Darmanin il y a pas longtemps nous dire
oui le travail c'est l'effort etc donc
on retourne complètement en arrière avec
une vision chrétienne du travail qui est
souffrance douleur du sang et des larmes
or ce qui peut voir c'est qu'il peut y
avoir une autre définition je dis pas
une valeur une autre définition du
travail bon donc le télétravail permet
peut-être à la fois plus de temps
personnel mais aussi une organisation
donc c'est pas la valeur travail qu'il
faut interroger c'est l'organisation du
travail plus courte quatre trucs
c'est ce que c'est pas tellement la
peine de travailler vraiment que que
on peut l'organiser autrement mais il
faut faire des efforts le travail c'est
pas ce ne sont pas des vacances sinon on
appellerait pas ça travaille
des vacances il y a des rythmes
différents et qu'on avait on peut faire
des efforts sans que ce soit horrible un
peu plus longtemps chaque jour et de
travailler que 4 jours par semaine
pourquoi
parce qu'on regarde effectivement les
métiers éligibles au télétravail c'est
pas les métiers les plus pénibles c'est
pas les métiers c'est généralement voilà
les CSP voilà et donc c'est encore moins
vrai
effectivement une fracture beaucoup plus
importante moi j'ai alors vous parlez
des agriculteurs moi j'étais ma
profession était je dépendais du monde
agricultrice j'ai travaillé 7 jours sur
7 dans un métier ou un métier passion
pendant des années et avec des
difficultés je travaille avec des
animaux donc pas possible de prendre des
vacances ou très enfin voilà j'ai pas
l'impression bon ok j'ai 50 ans un peu
voilà j'ai un petit peu plus dur le
matin quand je me réveille mais voilà
j'ai pas été abîmée par mon travail
je suis passionnée de ce que j'ai fait
et ce serait à refaire je referai tout
pareil je pense que le attention le
télétravail qui a l'air d'être annoncé
comme la panacée aujourd'hui va encore à
mon sens creuser des écarts dans la
manière dont on perçoit le travail les
métiers compliqués alors on parle de la
pénibilité qui bien sûr doit être un
critère qui rentre en ligne de compte
donc quand on est agriculteur on peut
pas parce que pour pouvoir arriver à un
niveau de retraite descend toute façon
faut y aller mais
mieux on le sait au départ en plus donc
on choisit pas ce métier là pour pour
avoir une belle retraite forcément quand
même quand on est agriculteur et quand
on fait des tonnes de métiers qui
demandent une certaine pénibilité au
sens le plus sympathique entre
guillemets du terme d'entendre parler de
douceur de de petits nids douillet en
télétravail dans son appartement avec
les enfants qui jouent à ses pieds et et
tout est choisi on est dans deux mondes
qui n'ont plus rien à voir
c'est quand même aussi preuve
la production de choses je voudrais
qu'on passe parce qu'il y aurait
de vivre aussi d'abord
la façon de résoudre cette crise qu'on
voit aujourd'hui en France sur cette
réforme des retraites alors il y aurait
bien une solution ce serait de consulter
le peuple ça serait le référendum mais
encore faudrait-il savoir se servir du
référendum si on savait s'en servir
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ça sera un moyen assez
idéal de sortir de la crise que Emmanuel
Macron dise voilà moi je pense que cette
réforme de retraite est nécessaire mais
je vois qu'il y a une opposition très
forte dans la rue donc je consulte les
Français
le début c'est le début du chaos total
quoi c'est que la réponse d'avance de
poser la question pourquoi on arrive pas
est-ce que est-ce que justement il
faudrait pas essayer d'avoir un regard
sur cette question une réflexion sur
cette question et se dire qu'après toi
homme au consulte des gens sur une
question il répond ce qu'il souhaite et
puis voilà on prend en compte c'est au
fond le référendum c'est c'est comme
c'est comme le Parlement c'est une façon
de faire une loi
Hollande poser une question par
référendum avoir une réponse et
s'asseoir sur la réponse en disant
monsieur référendum
des Landes
il y a eu réponse et il a dit bah non la
réponse ne me plaît pas donc elle va
faire alors ça c'était pas je suis tout
à fait pour le référendum comme ça je
veux dire Macron faudrait des questions
ou lui dire et non il y a pas finalement
mais c'est mieux oui bon la même chose
avec maastrique
c'est une c'est très bien à condition
que la réponse soit oui
donc mais quand même c'est dommage non
qu'on arrive pas la question elle doit
pas être est-ce que vous voulez partir à
64 ou 62 on va pas s'en sortir c'est
quels sont les conséquences dans un
schéma ou dans un autre vous cotisez
plus plus longtemps vous on peut
reparler de la retraite par
capitalisation aussi qui est un sujet
qui est un peu tard pourquoi personne ne
veut en parler il y a des paysages pas
si mal que ça voilà ou en partie par
capitalisation
en France elle existe déjà elle existe
déjà mais c'est comme si c'était un
sujet bizarrement tabou hein c'est un
personne je ne sais pas pourquoi oui
c'est d'ailleurs très très frappant que
tout le monde commence les discours
disons les Français sont très
attachésiens par les partitions mais oui
bon peut-être parce que peut-être qu'on
leur propose pas d'autres partition
dessus qu'on a toute la classe des
boomers au travail un peu de retraité
mais maintenant toute la classe des Baby
arrive à la retraite et qu'on a ce
rapport au travail qui est de plus en
plus distendu on va dire ça marche plus
donc mais ça c'est pardon mais c'est
quelque chose qu'on aurait pu anticiper
que les Baby moomers un jour prennent
leur retraite on avait quand même le
temps de le voir venir mais bon ça veut
dire qu'on a pris le problème des
retraites on l'a pas pris par le bon
bout mais parce que personne ne
travaille des seniors 5 ans 5 ans c'est
le mandat d'un élu alors ça pose
question aussi sur l'organisation
démocratique la plupart des élus ils
visent leur réélection ou celle de leur
voilà au bout de cinq ans des projets
structurants pour notre pays pardon mais
depuis Pompidou on n'en voit plus
beaucoup on a des échéances politiques
enfin des visions politiques qui sont
très court termiste et qui sont très
calés sur les cycles électoraux les on a
eu un commissaire on a eu un commissaire
au Plan sous le dernier pèlerinage je
vous rappelle que c'était très habile
c'était Monsieur Bayrou qui pouvait
comme ça être le seul accumulé plusieurs
mandats ne pas s'appliquer ce qu'il
demandait aux autres c'était une
solution pour pour garder son mandat de
merde
c'est même pas une question d'argent ces
gens-là ils seront dans le privé il
serait payé 3 fois plus donc c'est même
pas une question d'argent mais bon
pardon mais j'ai pas lu énormément de
production de Monsieur Bayrou sur son
Haut-Commissariat au plan on est juste
à mon avis bien meilleur que celui du
corps mais apparemment il sert pas
vraiment aujourd'hui de fondement au
départ il est pas mal du tout bon vous y
croyez pas c'est impossible on peut pas
éduquer les Français on pourrait pas
éduquer les Français au référendum ce
serait ça serait quand même intéressant
je pense que le référendum peut jouer au
niveau local
très précises et en définitive très
concrètes
au niveau sociétal les sujets comme la
fin de vie les sujets comme le mariage
pour tous qui rappelez-vous avait divisé
vraiment la société il y avait des gens
très énervés
sur des sujets des sujets sociétaux
c'est-à-dire derrière lesquels se cache
pas à une énorme machine financière
compliquée dans le on sait que c'est
trop compliqué quoi
la réponse était oui dans la retraite
est-ce que vous imaginez une seule
seconde monsieur Martinez accepté le
résultat du référendum mais jamais donc
de toute façon
qui est difficilement contestable
de la peine de mort au référendum à
l'époque
on était encore avec la guillotine
on peut pas mais admettons qu'on repose
la question de la peine de mort ce
serait plié aussi les ondir ah bah oui
donc effectivement aujourd'hui
la question de se pose pas donc
malheureusement
on s'est demandé au président de
s'engager et de dire de façon très
goliale voilà si c'est non je pars
parce que à chaque fois qu'il a été
utilisé notamment par De Gaulle c'est
devenu un peu le visite donc si vous
mettez un enjeu tel dans les référendum
évidemment plus personne n'en fait
au contraire moi je pense qu'il faudrait
des passionné totalement
la légitimité du président Macron qui a
fait sa campagne et tout son début de
quinquennat en disant je ferai cette
réforme des retraites je veux cet âge
alors il avait dit 65 il se calme sur 64
il se bat quand même pour ça et tout
d'un coup
un référendum on dirait bah finalement
on n'en veut pas et lui il serait droit
dans ses bottes vous en voulez pas c'est
pas grave je reste là la vraie question
c'est impossible la vraie question c'est
pas celle-là c'est que est-ce qu'il ne
peut pas peut rien faire parce que
justement il ne peut pas se représenter
est-ce que ça peut être une erreur la
réforme de 2008 justement
il y a pas de soutien politique il a une
cote de crédibilité de popularité qui
est tellement faible même pas 40%, un
peu plus de 30 % 32 33 ça suffit pas
avoir voilà ça suffit pas avoir un
soutien
que tout le monde ne pense qu'à ses
succession et puis il y a pas grand
pardon derrière enfin on sait bien que
que je sais plus comment s'appelle
Renaissance ne tient
sur Emmanuel Macron
à gauche il y a personne à droite il y a
personne
c'est qu'il y avait peut-être donc il a
fait table rase de tous ces oppositions
etc mais là c'est vraiment un désert
absolu il y a rien ni lui ni
on attend des hommes des hommes
politiques un peu brillants
voilà donc voilà notre se confond avec
le masculin enfin bravo enfin une allié
non c'était juste pour faire un lien
avec la suite bon
réformes
alors on va parler un petit peu d'un
sujet qui vous tient à cœur et un vrai
Chopard c'est c'est les femmes
puisqu'elles sont très présentes dans
ces mailles à la première ministre de la
présidente de l'Assemblée il y a hors
berger enfin et il y a aussi les femmes
dont on parle dans le dans le système de
la retraite alors est-ce que
Madame Macron
alors est-ce que l'égalité l'égalité
vraiment est-ce que ça existe entre les
hommes et les femmes
[Musique]
alors il y a un article que j'avais dit
qu'il m'avait un peu choqué qui disait
que Elisabeth borne pour être remercier
une fois que leur est fait dépasser 10
mois et 18 juin parce que dis-moi 18
jours c'était c'était ce qui avait fait
cresson donc si elle fait 10 mois et 19
jours elle aurait fait plus que cresson
pouvait la remercier à ce moment-là
vraiment on est à un niveau très bas
entre Edith Cresson ça veut dire
qu'elles ne sont pas capables d'être pas
mimi histoire
mais on verra bien ça aurait été un
homme il aurait été dans la même
difficulté bien sûr n'importe quel
premier ministre aujourd'hui
c'est comme c'est quand même c'est quand
même terrible de poser cette question de
d'avoir un article qui dit ça alors dans
un autre registre ces Valérie Pécresse
qui dans Le Parisien disait bah oui je
pensais à abandonner la vie politique
après la campagne présidentielle et puis
il y avait un exemple qui vous
intéressait c'est celui de
la première ministre de Nouvelle-Zélande
qui a posé sa démission c'était assez
intéressant alors le son cas est
vraiment très intéressant à tous les à
tous les points de vue d'abord bon on
voit ça sa photo c'est une femme c'est
la première femme en Nouvelle-Zélande
qui est première ministre
elle était jeune elle n'avait pas 40 ans
quand elle est arrivée comme premier
ministre et elle a eu un enfant pendant
que pendant son mandat de Premier
ministre elle n'a pas hésité alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est son action et
donc elle a eu affaire à deux graphes
crises elle est très très populaire deux
grattes crises la l'attaque contre les
musulmans à tric Church de mosquée avec
des dizaines de morts où elle a montré
une très grande empathie mais avec de la
sincérité ce qui est pas toujours le cas
quand il y a un drame de la part des
hommes politiques qui ont des comme on
dit les éléments de langage
et puis la deuxième crise comme dans les
autres pays ça a été celle du covid et
là on a vu que c'était pas simplement
quelqu'un d'empathique de gentil etc
puisque elle a eu une position où
finalement très très sévère très très
stricte elle a fermé le pays et la poser
des
mesures très rigoureuses tout en étant
finalement
rester populaire et puis tout d'un coup
surprise elle dit je m'en vais je suis
Premier ministre je n'ai plus l'énergie
et c'est là que ça devient pour nous
intéressons c'est que pour la première
fois une personne s'en va non pas parce
qu'elle est démissionnée ou qu'elle part
une personne n'a été politique ou parce
que elle a des casseroles ou des ou des
procès qui qui s'annoncent etc
qu'il ne dit pas pour raison personnelle
qui en général sont très floues et qui
dit je n'ai plus l'énergie et je ne
serai plus capable de d'être à la
hauteur de ce que vous me demandez et
elle fait le rapport entre les
privilèges de la fonction qui sont
indéniable et les obligations les
responsabilités elle dit je vais pas
garder les privilèges et puis
ne plus ne plus rien faire et donc ça
c'est intéressant parce que on voit
qu'elle pose un autre problème qui est
celui de l'usure du pouvoir et c'est dur
de pouvoir elle se manifeste
du côté début d'avant des gouvernants
elle a l'impression elle sait elle s'est
usée et cette usure peut-être néfaste
pour son sa façon de gouverner mais
l'usure elle est aussi du côté des des
populations qui demandent de plus en
plus aujourd'hui où tout va très vite
qui demande un renouvellement du
personnel politique et elle elle a
réussi à comprendre ça alors évidemment
les mauvaises langues disent les
élections qui ne doivent avoir lieu chez
eux en octobre prochain
donne la droite et le centre droit
c'est-à-dire ses adversaires les
gagnants auquel cas de toute façon on
aurait dû partir mais c'est pas
c'est pas la vraie raison mais c'est pas
faux non moi je dirais les choses
autrement je dirais que elle se
positionne par rapport à ces élections
pour trouver le bon moment pour partir
c'est ni trop près ni trop loin mais
elle ne part pas parce qu'elle est
perdante puisqu'elle pense que son parti
peut encore gagner et il peut encore
gagner et ceci dit elle n'abandonne pas
non plus elle ne tourne pas le dos à la
politique puisqu'elle va retrouver son
siège elle va retrouver son siège de
député et donc c'est pas aussi d'énergie
pour mener aussi cette campagne qui est
difficile il y a aussi
parlé de la campagne
une vingtaine d'années pour vraiment
juger de l'authenticité de cette
décision parce que si beaucoup d'hommes
politiques et là je dirais en tant que
femme politique elle se place
véritablement comme le majorité des
hommes politiques c'est-à-dire
probablement avec des choix des choix de
carrière etc que peut-être c'est un bon
moment pour s'en aller se mettre un peu
recule pour mieux revenir on sait pas et
ce qui ne pas du tout une tare mais
voilà
il faut est-ce qu'il faut
au-delà de ça la sanctifié tout ça parce
qu'elle démissionne elle est presque
dire c'est presque trop
intéressant c'est intéressant est-ce que
un peu méchant pour les femmes c'est une
femme elle est sympa elle s'en va non
c'est pas ça c'est une femme c'est pas
parce qu'elle s'endort
c'est une femme
c'est très original
parce qu'on n'a pas tellement de femmes
jeunes qui arrivent comme chef de
gouvernement
parce qu'il nous reste plus beaucoup de
temps et justement enfin réagissez à ça
mais sur ce problème de l'égalité femme
homme en politique j'ai l'impression
qu'on a encore beaucoup de combat à
mener oui de combat ou de temps le temps
fait aussi son œuvre bien sûr on dit
généralement qu'une femme doit prouver
qu'elle est légitime doit prouver on
demande beaucoup plus de technicité
au début quand on disait quand on
appelait le maire je me retournais pour
savoir qui on demandait tout à fait tout
à fait c'est exactement ça une femme
ne peut il faut en permanence quel juste
ici mais je pense que c'est également ça
dans le monde professionnel dans les
conseils d'administration des choses
comme ça il y a pas qu'en politique la
femme doit être pour doit se légitimer
en permanence doit être technicienne
doit être vous avez l'image de Valérie
Pécresse derrière qui a eu du mal à
trouver l'équilibre justement entre la
responsable politique et la technicienne
mais on ne nous pardonne pas d'être
prise en défaut je me souviens de
ramaillade je crois qui était mise à
Jeunesse et des Sports à un moment et
quand elle a été nommée on lui a été
interrogé par un journaliste je ne sais
plus quel média qui lui demandait et
combien de joueurs dans une équipe de
basket et quelle est la durée de la
mi-temps de machin mais on aurait jamais
demandé ça
a été pareil
voilà la femme doit en permanence se
justifier en même temps le challenge est
beau moi ça me fait partie de moi je
suis pas inquiète on est dans une
société où on sait qu'on a un héritage
quand même euh
à apporter ou ce sera plus compliqué ou
la on dit souvent de la femme qu'elle
est autoritaire alors que l'homme a de
l'autorité on a effectivement un petit
peu ce qui est intéressant c'est pas
tant la question qu'on lui a posé c'est
la réponse qu'elle est apportée
lorsqu'elle savait qu'on y avait de
joueurs dans une équipe de basket ou pas
c'est ça la question
sans savoir exactement comme
en France ni de porte-avion ben quand on
veut être président de la République ou
président de la République c'est quand
même un minimum
c'est souvent les femmes qu'on va
chercher alors vous avez compris que
j'étais pas une féministe acharnée je
pense que je ne suis pas pour l'égalité
moi je suis pour la complémentarité je
pense qu'on ne sera pas du tout je sais
pas du tout d'accord avec vous moi je
pense qu'on est dans des positions
le plus c'est qu'on nous ramène
systématiquement à notre condition de
femme ou de manque de femmes on va aller
enfin moi j'étais très choquée quand le
président de la République a choisi
Elisabeth borne comme première ministre
parce que sa condition n°1 c'était
prendre une femme et ben non si elle
prend quelqu'un
c'est exactement la vision essentialiste
que les féministes répliquent combattent
comme s'il y a des naissances de la
femme
merci merci beaucoup à tous les quatre
voilà l'émission est terminée
malheureusement et bon on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro de PAF
[Musique]